wake up, son, wake up,
wake up
when Christina Lester moved to Palm
Springs, California, in 2020,
she considered sending her son
Daniel to the local elementary
school.
I saw a school across the street
from my house, so I started to
think, well, maybe he could go to
the district school.
But at Julius Corzine Elementary,
the students score well below the
state average in English and math.
There was no way that I was going to
send my son to a failing school.
So Daniel attends Pome Academy,
which is part of the Springs Charter
School Network.
Like all charters.
The school is publicly funded, so
there's no tuition bill and last
feels it's well equipped to serve
Daniel's special needs.
And we leave around
seven o'clock.
I drive thirty five minutes
to 40 minutes away
because it's a charter park academy
accepts students from as far away as
the next county over.
The problem is it doesn't provide
transportation.
Having the lack of transportation to
get our children to school is
hurting the need for the resources
for single parents like myself and
low income families.
We need them the most, but yet we
still don't have them available.
And this is a nationwide problem
that limits parental choice.
Although it varies by district,
about two thirds of states don't
require districts to provide
transportation for charter school
students.
Like many things in public
education, the orientation
that school districts and the public
sector tends to have toward school
transportation is that the clients
of the schools are the school
districts rather than the clients or
the parents and what they need.
Andrew Rotherham is a co-founder
at the nonprofit Bellwether
Education Partners, which has been
studying how school transportation
limits parental choice.
A lot of places it's a struggle
for parents to get their kids to
a charter school in suburbs that are
very car dependent where people may
have to go great distances, choices
start to become out of reach.
The one group it was substantial for
low income minority kids end up
going the furthest to get to
schools. That's a function of
parents being in communities where
they may not have a schooling option
that they want and having to go go a
great distance to avail themselves
of one
K ready to go.
I think in Jesus name.
Amen.
Have a good day.
After I dropped him off at
school, I'll just go to the park.
Typically, I'll spend my whole day
there in meetings,
back to back or on phone calls.
I don't have any Wi-Fi
at the park.
If I have these the bathroom, I'll
just go to the park
bathroom.
The longest hours that I've sat
in the car at the park or is the
like from 8:30 in the morning to
4:30?
If Daniel was provided
with transportation to get to
school, I could do my work
more efficiently.
Hi, my name is Christina Laster.
I'm the director of policy and
legislation with the National
Parents Union.
Last year, who spent nearly 13 years
in the San Diego Public School
System, now works in education
reform.
There is no funding from the state
of California that
is offered to charter schools
for transportation.
It's not even a line item on
their budget, like we have a local
control funding formula.
We have what is called the local
control and Accountability Plan, and
there are no resources granted for
public charter schools.
Opponents might say the state
already has offered parents an
education that's close to their
home. That's what zoned neighborhood
schools are.
Why should they be required to
transport kids to another
neighborhood or another county just
because their parents are
dissatisfied with local schools?
It really comes down to what is your
vision for the public
education system?
The school choice argument is
actually the system should be
responsive to the parents.
They are the ultimate stakeholders.
That's how you preserve political
support for public education.
I would never send Daniel to the
district school because I know what
that's like. I've been there before
with him. We've experienced what
the data shows.
Before they relocated to Palm
Springs, Daniel was enrolled in a
public school in the town of Lake
Elsinore last year, sued
the school for mistreatment and for
failing to meet Daniel's learning
needs.
Shortly after the case was settled,
they moved away because Laster said
she was the victim of domestic
violence.
By the time Daniel was in first
grade, the teacher mistreated
him by the second grade.
He was emotionally vanquished,
he had suicidal ideation
and he didn't want to go to school
every day. And so I decided
to immediately pull him
out of that school
in that school district and
homeschool him.
But after probably about
a year and a half, I
recognize that that
can become very expensive.
And one of those years I
enrolled him in Springs
Public Charter School
around the same time.
Right, Daniel?
Three hours till
we were to look at what happens
with African-American or black
males in this country,
if they're able to read and write
then and if they're excessively
punished, that's what we call the
school to prison pipeline.
I don't want my son on the school to
prison pipeline.
I want him to stay on the path he's
he's at grade level.
He's not building in English
language arts or math,
which is huge for fifth grade black
boys in the state of California.
Despite Daniel's academic progress,
Laster is considering homeschooling
him again to avoid the commute.
The Springs Charter School Network
offers programs that support
homeschool families and study at
home education school
transportation.
It's for a lot of people.
It's like the plumbing in your
house. It's not something you think
about much until it doesn't work.
The pandemic has forced
that to the fore. Now people are
paying attention to school
transportation because of these
shortages and so forth.
But these are long standing issues
of a system that just doesn't work
as well as it could, but kind of is
in the background and people aren't
thinking about.
And some of these issues we're
seeing now around choice and parents
wanting different things are going
to bring that to the surface.
I especially believe that
for parents like myself
that are single parents
being able to be offered
a resource to allow their
kids to get to that quality school
of, you know, of their choosing
is a must.
Hi everybody.
I am not going to be on camera.
I may be multi-tasking, but I'm
present in the meeting.
I've done everything that I possibly
can with them. A day I can become
very overwhelmed.
I want my son to be educated, I want
my son to have upward mobility, so
I sacrifice now to
make sure that he has the best
outcomes possible later in life.